plan I'm playing as the weenie hey guys
and gals its markiplier here back at it
again with another amazing let's play
with the boys say hi the boys hi it's us
the pillow do I get to pick who witch
hunter I am hey Bob legs my scream here
and welcome to the goatman its I'm here
with Mark and way we didn't say anything
like he's hot here to up various kinds
ignite do your intro would hey guys
welcome back to the goatman this time
with Mark and Bob not played this in a
while I'm curious if anything has
changed the thing I'm the skull mask
Ranger boy okay wait you look more like
the sunglass guy Saul become is you do
wear a lot of denim mark that's pretty
good for you that is me I master the
Canadian tuxedo basically 80% denim
denim and cloak it's all you wear right
pretty much we're in it right now
you guys ready to hunt I'm yeah I am
we've been ready it hold the can 23rd
2019 when they call her home in the
Green Hill Amelia and it what village
should be capitalized I'm just saying it
was alleged that a mysterious creature
attacks people animals fun this collar
military research team set out military
military and research military guns
Research Corporation what happens when
you shoot it I don't know Oh way just
spawned from the earth whoa what does he
see that did you see wait spotted from
the air for no I did not see that I
don't over this game being third person
third person that's weird they're like
controls or something yeah they're
probably control vvvv put solution
[Music]
hell yeah bro well can I talk about the
beds in here we get cozy up in here do
you see the three beds oh yeah oh yeah
boys why would you turn the compass off
hey guys have you at sea
priceless Lee valuable information
appears on screen it does take up a lot
of real estate I'll say I suppose but
why would you not want that also oh I
thought those were like stove burners I
was like 15 burners Watson oh hey here's
our computer so here's where the cameras
go was life for like half a second
pressing see turns on your compass we
know that's way more man than goat that
I thought it would be I think the
appropriate name would be goat demon
what the hell was that thing Oh
one-sixth of his damage already so
that's let's just stand around away from
and come back and shoot him some more
Jesus wait why are my shotgun so delayed
in sound welcome to go wait watch now my
my shotguns gonna explode three what you
heard it right shotgun yeah it just
works I'm gonna count down five
four three two why am i why is my
control over okay now what is this oh my
god if you hit Z something horrible
happens to your controls why would you
want that the world that's horrifying
I'm a play like this guy duck hunt mode
I know it's kind of cool I kind of like
it actually it's it's kinda it's got an
appeal to it so on the compass the
church and the graveyard or this way
alright cool right let's do it man I'm
just so glad to be hunting goat man with
my buddies yeah I love hunting goat yeah
I love hot men oh that's different
oh my God look at this empty miss you
should come stand somewhere out here
where I can shoot with my gun oh okay
I'm turning off VR mode oh no I'm
glitched into some rocks oh boy okay we
just passed a house how do we just
passed a house I'm over here with bum
bum where's the house where's the house
back across the river it's right here oh
how did I miss that
what happened god these crickets are
just so great now that chirping noise is
like gonna destroy my ears Alexian can
you cut out that frequency Landy audio
can you apply several layers of d home
to this and ruin the audio no listen
that that buzzing is that a very
specific frequency if you cut out that
frequency that buzzing goes away but
that's the same as my voice
[Laughter]
beautiful classic Wade mannerisms is it
really that easy to kill like I know we
haven't this healed like evolved or
something because we did a fair amount
of damage considering he walked up on us
completely unawares and unprepared yeah
so Church or green okay wait just don't
answer Bob's question or something over
there what is that is that dangerous
over that way she weren't looking I got
my c4 going let me put out a landmine
for this bad boy or bad frog what are
the what are the Flair's doing wait I
see oh my god well I forget what I was
talking about first mine yeah can I get
these mines back west of us I saw Orange
glowy stuff like goat man stuff those
landlines work the landmines are potent
oh god I got bit by a snake
what oh [ __ ] is this see if thieves
actually did a lot of damage where is
that snake I'll shoot him in the face
it's right in front of me
it's barely sticking out of the grass I
got c4 here
how do i shut off c4 when it's right
next to me how do I set it off I'll go
where is it there it is how do I set it
off I don't know
got it all right
no I didn't I just made it angrier wait
wait okay back off wait wait back away
back away
oh my god
what the snake dead I don't see it I
think you got it it's not hissing
anymore well my mouse is on screen now
so that's music all of our nice tools on
snakes and bears oh that's so military
look do mines kill bears does c4 kill us
I'm here to hunt a man
oh don't care which one it is I'm gonna
administer some research to the church
the church I'm gonna heal up are you are
you doing research in here
I'm trying research for researching
these windows Margit wouldn't we shoot
what 100 the Satan is outside what oh
God oh holy I'm dead what I'm dead
can you guys like save me where'd you go
I'm outside in the grass dead oh you got
snake oh it just says you died oh well
all right well you know I can
posthumously blow myself up I can't live
without you
what's happening and why am i staring at
a wall so I think what have both Jesus
Christ
you're hot [ __ ]
[Music]
so those snakes will like insta kill you
if they more than one bites you that one
snake that way half my health and like
one bite that's crazy
yeah so go band's not super difficult
but the environment and some of the
stuff you can trigger like that can
wreck you fast alright let's let's go
after this go I don't actually like the
sniper his guns kind of annoying I'll
trade you you be shoddy I'll be sniping
Wow like our logo for a team icon yeah
salty well there it is there we go
weirdly shaped bean well it's the best I
could do as you guys like any of these
other ones better
like that guy he's cool yeah that's a
tree now okay well we certainly okay
we're doing research you can do the
science flask science class science our
military research team is ready to go
make sure you have plenty of science
flasks to conduct your research boys
whoa
yes see you guys seen how good we are
parkour whoop whoop it is and we can
exploit by being on top of here for the
go maybe not oh can I ride the drone can
I ride the drone fly me on the drone I'm
gonna get them from the sky I don't know
how to do the drone controls so wait
drone be by dial it's worth the
beginning okay I've got very late oh
wait if I jump you can go up hang on we
can do this just be chill only go like
straight up and down
yep go go okay that's not really working
shall we put some landmines and down oh
geez tell me when your button lit Jesus
Christ man
putting landmines down Oh God what
there's a big marker we need good job
wasn't that first I was right next to
you
I'm putting landmine
down all right good no where's it go I
don't know do I wait here wait for me we
want to go out I think that one trapped
into landmines will pretty much do it
let's just wait here yeah let's just see
what happens
can I put a mine on the trap oh yeah
prove this works Oh Chad tell him okay
it's not really how this works either
okay guys go watch my bod I hear some oh
no wait that's a plane outside there man
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry sir I'm not seeing any goats up
here or men's well thankfully we have
area around this camp if he comes from
that one direction he is [ __ ] so roasted
if he comes from that way oh my god is
there a way to track him this place is
huge
well we can go to the marked things in
the compass sounds stupid you're stupid
well weird should happen with whatever
you guys did the last time at the church
stupid yeah and then we died I don't
want to do that again alright maybe we
should go to the bar here can I just
stay on the drone and I'll just be your
guys I in the sky okay yeah but if you
get smacked in the butt you might regret
it that's probably fine probably fine
wait wait can I
oh he's coming he's coming
no he's not
I heard him roar right orange I would
see him from my perch in the sky you
know what screw you guys I'm going to
the barn by myself with you know by
myself I'm with you all right fine
we're going to the barn by ourselves by
ourselves there's a tree oh [ __ ] oh god
bear mark there's landmine befall you
had someone with a shotgun to help you
oh my god it dodged my mind don't worry
Oh ball drone it to death is it dead no
it's bouncing on marsh [ __ ] okay it's
dead okay slide on this whole time so I
was having trouble see all right I don't
think I did either where's my get off
the magical drone and come help whatever
we don't need you kit I guess you have
to place it down then like Presley you
wanted or something do you want to drive
charges I didn't grab it are you hurt
yes very much so extremely actually whoa
you okay you are you for use I'm going
to the barn oh [ __ ] this is spooky
couple of stupid bear
and it's dead I'm the greatest shot in
the world
it's barn there's a hell look at the
barn what's in the barn oh my god the
house is just full of trash for some
reason oh hey Mark there's another first
aid kit up here if you need one
get it another landmine here seen you
thought we had a limited number of those
we got plenty of landmines there's
churches all over this country churches
in real life what makes a change in mind
was not in the house the land mine was
in the barn which is the church work
house go to worship okay I'm coming to
plan a thing okay bear trap kind of the
mouth of thing planet land mines planet
okay breathe do it that way Wow we did
like 25% as hell more he's stuck not
dumb baby
not even that fast go douche come here
move the barn got him dick ever made
excellent work so what what caused him
to show up here I was in the barn and he
just oh he's back he's back he whoa whoa
whoa he wants more he was born he was
born
yeah command me oh oh yeah oh oh wait
did he close that door Oh
close the door Oh City he was barely
dark the c4 it's right by the door
you got shoe tit hey it's going away
he's a big fish Oh God is a pissed-off
deer goat whoa oh is that good or bad
how do we get in the thing we can't get
in the thing
wait there's like a side door over here
I think guys let's go there's a
pissed-off Pig wait you guys just gotta
come outside mark you're being chased by
a pig what do you mean no I'm not oh yes
I am
oh you are being chased by his dog he
goes right to French's Satan Pig
you see that [ __ ] he walked right
through that fish he sure did he sure
did you right you right you are Satan
Pig Satan Pig like alright well we got a
there's left you're mine who needed
another mine well I used up all my
mountains but mark inhabits in the barn
you just have to come through that side
door over here yeah right there on the
table
all right cool coming for it no
recognise you through all the scare
well whatever man maybe you should grow
some balls some boys some girls one of
the flares - should I shoot players at
him when he comes that good thing to do
maybe that might scare him off so he
doesn't like attack here yeah we pretty
much just want him to come and die cuz
it sucks you guys did some serious demo
for pine village do this way he went
towards amber pine oh yeah near got him
wow I'm a good shot what was that just a
normal deer are we just murdering
everything we find probably gunshot and
three two one one deers we are here for
research right anything - Oh neato this
is safe
feel like we could trap this bring
return to your home there's our big red
actually it's a relatively small red
post-it note here that just says return
to your home on it that's not how you
pick it up how do you pick it up
well what why here whoa whoa holy [ __ ]
if you have any Minds put them on the
bridge and then loom overhead yeah yay I
can't place anything on the bridge June
um I'm slightly shooting through you
mark are you okay I'm fine thank you for
asking
oh my god okay all right so I learned
you can't plant anything on the bridge
interesting good I'm gonna play to help
get over here and heal up I had already
used this health kit and I just got more
uses out of it yeah you get five when
you pick it back up it restart it goes
back to five when you set it down though
it should go back to normal I think it's
just glitched in the no I was just doing
it and using it oh it's just fully
refilling itself I have a broken
first-aid kit I am the healer let's go
to that village we did not do very much
damage to goat man that time I think it
was deal like a shit-ton
I think comparatively to bullets
explosives seem to be effective surprise
I think we should use explosives on them
I think we should use explosives on them
ah you might be right about to explode
don't put my bladder once you get to the
village then you can go to the bathroom
but you got a hole I don't know if I can
make it
it's literally only 300 meters away it's
it's not that you know you know a feat
that is I mean like a thousand and one
hundred and something oh you lost me at
uh you said um but whatever um thousand
Wow God fall damage is real ah fall
damage hurts these med kits just
restocked as soon as you pick it back up
that's awesome it's just like real life
yeah one's mind up the churches have
land mines
the first date is infinite yes fun why
medical prices in America are so
reasonable who's in a research team give
me all your research just being real
quick shake all done
wait I thought you had to be in real
wait what's the button to shake your
peepee in this game v no be no and no
you literally just did it unless you're
a liar liar
the shake your pee-pee button it's just
like a button you have or you don't
you're not cool there's some [ __ ]
there's no land mines anywhere in this
city I got like five land mines so
you're just going to the wrong Church
this is a bad place there's no Church
here come come check out these guys have
a custom build stone pizza oven in their
living room looks really interesting
that's so interesting don't be like that
enthralled I'm enthralled Marc come to
me I don't know sexy 403 no it's not
what the hell is that what is that oh
it's my icon Deportes e for if i walk
away from it stays oh oh it just stays
there yeah it's like a magic trick what
happened oh well well you know here let
me give you another one there is yep no
that would be really funny if it
exploded as like an exploit
where was it mine wait where was mine up
here thank you
so how do we summon the goat demon yeah
how do we sum the goat demon well how'd
you guys Bob did you grab that red flyer
on the bridge mmm yes
maybe I think I was too fine like those
red flyers or something like that
oh there's one right here yeah grab it
only good things should have a bit it's
just readable if he gets all here and he
goes in I turn on fancy mode
oh boy what about that see that's the
messed up controls mode
where is it where's that goddamn blue
it's a it's a rail shooter' now boys
point me at him and then make sure he's
taste in front of me we go to the church
we had fun at the church but I laid out
bare airs on me but I laid out this
awesome trap here if he gets anywhere
near here he's gonna die there's two
mines to c4 if he gets in these trap
he's dead
that's true I guess we should just stand
here and stare at the traps yeah what
else would we do man I want to go to the
graveyard to the graveyard all by my
with you what did you just say what all
bye bye with you oh no Bob are you
understanding what we'd say no but this
is wrong if I don't care I'll buy my
with you it's our thing we do you
remember the times Oh make a churching
sound oh all by myself but all by my
with you I get it why is that the thing
we do it's us I don't think so us is we
and that is us okay I'm very confused
anyway are we gonna make her stand in
the graveyard
yeah well I'm probably gonna die of
snakes or whatever so let's do this
let's do this I gotta say it's not the
most thrilling of moments in between the
go
there's no ambiance there's no suspense
alright I'm staying away from the
entrance of the church when the snakes
appear I know I'm going into the church
and China I guess I play in this let
your explosives god damn it I knew that
was gonna happen
god dammit you [ __ ] I don't sweetie
oh my god you guys suck so bad I hate
every of you peel up I can't yeah
yo Hill I'm trying
we'll do it better try harder kill you I
hate you all of you
snakes are dying we good oh really oh
really and really the church oh really
we're fine everything's fine out here oh
god oh god but if you have any landmines
playing him up babe [ __ ] holy sweet
Jesus
oh [ __ ] he's coming into right entrance
he came in the wrong answers wait back
up
wait back up
oh no don't run away alright well there
he goes
got one land mind off on him well I
would have trapped everything up so
nicely if we did just been patient I
don't know why it went off right away
only we grabbed the thing to me I didn't
do anything at all I hate all right I
hate you there's another there's another
Healy box wait guys there's more Church
I'm fine oh you should come over here in
where where I can't see you I'm up the
hill behind the church I hope guys stay
safe without me okay goodbye fine oh
it's all glowy in this church yeah it's
cool this is cool right it's right I'm
going in looks not friendly yeah I don't
know what kind of church this is well
weird Bob I'm gonna go back to the
caravan I'm a finished highway that
probably sounds good
imma finish this fight I keep thinking
I'm seeing dragons flying in the
distance and then I realize that's not
what this game is about and then I get
really confused you never know they
could have done the dragon update and
goats are kind of like dragons I tried
to think of the game that way thank you
upgraded drag this guy rifle really
sucks does it it's not great it's just
hard to aim all right
let's trap up here and just wait for him
to show up here I'm gonna put a bear
trap here with the c4 on it where
everyone can see it okay good
whoa that's a lot of minds all right
cool whoa
bear bear bear no dear I got him head
shots go deer noscoped him ride in the
head are where's the a Bob
oh the brother if you look at the clouds
that's pretty cool whoa there they go
[ __ ] since the date how dare you
compliment those clouds I see a bear
coming in from far away but now it's
dead
okay the sniper elbow is pretty powerful
I gotta admit all right
Oh oh god no okay it wasn't hurting me
but those were simply sparks yeah no it
makes marks good thing Bob tried again
where is he
do we stop keep moving to other places
for him to attack us there's like
certain trigger points like I think you
can trigger him at the villages which we
didn't get him to trigger it want the
one I don't know why I think we go to
Greenfield we can trigger him we have to
point like all of our stuff and be ready
to kill them because I think it's really
hard to find him if you're not at the
trigger point okay all right I'm
gathering up the [ __ ] again we'll be
very careful Bob thanks for helping yeah
bad literally see wait standing behind
you in the distance not even flying a
drone so I'm just standing here stance
this light gather up your [ __ ] wait yeah
come on wait a couple lights how about
the important stuff no guys I'm flying
the drone under the truck is this
important very well you're an idiot oh I
actually flew the drone under the truck
is that bad um yeah let's be strict
about what you did all right this is a
drone beneath earth now why cuz I can't
find this money it just you see the
symbol it's directly below the Sun won't
pop up to pick
I'm surrounded by idiots I'm working on
important stuff here I'm going to the
bathroom you guys do whatever you're
doing I'm back now
Oh is he here oh no oh god help me if I
can see you
oh hey I'm going to the village if this
thing comes and kills me when I'm in the
village I blame you all for my doom why
we're right behind you no you're not
we're literally right here with you guys
I mean we could be another closer I am
alone loneliness is my only friend I
mean that might be true but like we are
also in existence lonely alone
we didn't have any like claims on
friendship we said claims on proximity I
[Music]
can't help with that could have sex one
what I was just trying to help you with
your loneliness I'm just trying to be a
good reason for research for research
don't get any other ideas but like for
research
anything is okay to try once for
research village plant [ __ ] bombs
everywhere are you kidding me this demon
was a ghost I saw mark there are bombs
right next to you careful kill oh my god
oh my god I've warned you what do you
want from me
Marcia c4 my neck my intent is to back
up if you planted it behind me well
coincidence what can I say Oh things
there that thing went right for our
bombs that wanted them I know what the
hell there yeah what's up bear Oh what
no what stop setting I'm so close to you
you gotta suck it all right guys mark
don't step back and putting bomber here
I just closed off that route of access
for research oh my god I'm going up to
this cabin up here
don't follow me [ __ ] it Bob's going I'm
going to myself look at that I hate you
so much wonder where that which one mark
don't go backwards I'm putting a bomb
behind you I feel like some of our traps
have been spaced out a little better
did one of you shoot me I am a little
bit of Health like bullets worth okay
just calm down
it's gonna trigger it happened to you
you're just gonna do it to me
No
don't do it then fine do it just don't
back up it'll be fine do it just do it
stop turning and don't back up I'm not
moving see everything's fine okay all
right
oh the bear oh it's a bear Jesus you big
pansy and that's kind of disappointing
yeah I thought it was something
important I like our half circle of
Defense's we have set up here these
lights really don't turn do they all
right I think our core to you guys
what do you mean part cords go through
the gaps nah I think you should
definitely try and jump over all of this
I think that did it
I can't believe that worked I can't
believe I'm absolutely astounded for
research husband let's try where's this
goddamn goat I like how all the doors
are closed until you get close enough
and then the game is like oh sorry hey
goat man I slept with your mom that was
him nothing I could discern from where
that emanated such a mystery
your sister is a [ __ ]
oh my god it makes the whole area red
what happened rice wait what happens if
I do this for you oh there we go
I'll do it okay what a nice ambience
what a sweet aisle Baines I love beans
all right where is this [ __ ] goddamn
it okay I'm gonna throw myself on one of
these traps if he doesn't show up in two
seconds I did accidentally just on I
don't know where it plays oh I tried to
play some mind behind you mark and I
think it went into the rock no it's bad
it's in the barn
that's right here how I got it in there
right
ah are you dead found it did you just
die yeah I died god damn you I just
wanted out I'm not I'm gonna take a
break if you guys are gonna keep laying
this is insanely boring I mean you're
not oh there's a deer oh no a deer well
got these deer more attracted to the
sound of violence than anything
pig imma blow myself up if you can't
beat the animals oh I blew up so hard my
goons had them too we almost had them
yep
let's see and recreate the ending of it
so that we actually killed the goat man
put in your rendition of the goat man
put in the three of us next to each
other all shootin him screaming at the
top of our lungs and he shot we shout
him to death an idiot said explodes okay
let's see Dana I didn't listen to go to
youtube and steal mine that was fun
no it was fun at first I mean see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]